le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
un lieu gratuit et ludique un
encadrement professionnel des animations
variées à l'espace régler de saint denis
le département met à disposition du
public
le coin des enfants un lieu d'échangés
de rencontres pour les jeunes de 0 à 12
ans qui favorise la culture
l'apprentissage et les loisirs laurence
est assistante maternelle cindy une mère
de trois enfants
toutes deux ont adopté le coin des
enfants dans leur quotidien un petit
café quelques gâteaux sans oublier un
brin de ménage chez laurence c'est
l'heure de la dînette assistante
maternelle depuis six ans elle s'occupe
tous les jours de quatre enfants âgés de
11 mois à 4 ans et demi et si
l'assistante maternelle chéri ses petits
protégés
il faut parfois canaliser leur énergie
pour laurence les sorties sont
indispensables activités de rencontrer
d'autres personnes
socialiser avec les autres enfants c'est
important deux fois par semaine
laurence emmène donc sa petite troupe au
coin des enfants à l'espace régler cet
ancien collège a été réhabilité par le
département
objectif proposer un lieu de vie un
centre culturel et communautaire aux
familles c'est dans cet environnement
que la structure d'accueil des petits a
ouvert ses portes il y a deux ans le
coin les enfants c'est un projet
expérimental qui date de 2014 mise en
place donc par la bibliothèque
départementale ça a pris forme
ici à l'espace réglé l'objectif c'est
mettre en exergue l'éveil des enfants
mais l'éveil des enfants à travers des
activités on l'a dit manuelles
culturelles artistiques musique et
surtout l'éveil à la lecture
et cela ça c'est aussi avec ceux qui
accompagnent ces enfants c'est aussi un
lieu où on permet donc l'insertion
parce qu'on a des professionnels mais
aussi on a des jeunes qui sont en
insertion qui peuvent venir ici faire
d'une une formation est quelque part
trouver leur voie professionnelle
ce matin laurence et son groupe profite
d'ailleurs d'un atelier lecture pour
l'assistante maternelle
cette structure répond à un vrai besoin
dans le milieu sur saint denis il ya
deux lieux d'accueil pour les enfants le
la peau chaude on initie le coin des
enfants au collège ridley non il y en a
pas assez pour le nombre d'assistantes
maternelles qui assure saint denis c'est
pas suffisant
une aubaine pour les professionnels mais
aussi pour les particuliers le coin des
enfants est ouvert à tout public
il est devenu une étape incontournable à
la sortie de l'école pour cindy et sa
petite famille mais là jamais toi là moi
je mets là pour faire des saints on
vient généralement avec mes enfants
trois fois par semaine donc
essentiellement après l'école le mardi
le jeudi et le vendredi
donc pour qu'ils puissent faire
essentiellement
leur devoir puisque au coin des enfants
propose l'aide aux devoirs on recommence
chaque race
sur place des médiateurs accompagne les
familles après l'effort le réconfort
les enfants peuvent participer à des
séances de relaxation ou se défouler en
s'amusant
pour des familles qui n'ont pas
forcément les moyens de payer des cours
de soutien ou même payer des activités
pour leurs enfants
là on a quand même un lieu
adapté pour se retrouver aussi parent
enfant je trouve que c'est voilà c'est
un lieu idéal et c'est vrai que depuis
que j'ai connu moi je l'étais plus
gratuit encadré diversifier le coin des
enfants ne fait pas seulement le bonheur
des petits mais aussi des plus grands
le coin des enfants s'adresse aux
enfants de 0 à 12 ans et leur famille il
propose des ateliers d aides aux devoirs
et une offre culturelle variée
le coin des enfants accueillent
gratuitement le public à l'espace régler
les mardi jeudi vendredi de 15h à 18h et
les mercredis et samedis de 10h à 18h un
accueil spécifique pour les 0 à 3 ans
est proposée le mercredi et vendredi
matin de 9h à 11h pour plus de
renseignements vous pouvez vous rendre
sur le site du département au
www.cegedim.fr
m